κάναμε την ευάφη με δην ιορδανία η οποία μας εδώσεν τη διν τ ότι ήταν
α έχουμε τέσσερα πττικ μέσα και φυσικά ήταν η πρώτη δυσκολη θυμούμεν ήρταντατα πττικά την
ημέρα που ξέσπασε υπύρκα ι άλιφανταστείτε μέσα σε σε τέσσερις μήνες είχα είχαμε καταφέρει να
φέρουμε ενουσιαστικά καις είχαμετα γιωμετά σε όλο το καλοκαίρι τω μεκαλύτερο αριθμόν σε επτθητικά προτεύοντα
μέσα που είχε η κυπριακή δημοκρατία γιατί είναι τόσο δύσκολον οι χώρα μας στα τόσα
χρόνια να αποκτήσει δικάτη στηρικά μές αποκλειστικά ταδα δην περιμένο ότι θα μας είναι καιάσουν
άλλες χώρες κιατ είαι τόσο δύσκολο να τα αποκτσουμε ταξει ιδεν είναι θέμα δυσκολίες είναι
τόσο θέμα ηλοποίησης τον διαδικασιών που υπήρχαν οι η προσπάθεια έτσι ι πρώτες συμβάσεισαν δεν
κάμνο λάφος για να αποκτηθού τα ιδιόκτητα είχαν βγεή τοκόσδιο δεν υπήρξαν γόνιμη διαγωνισμί εμείς
αυτό το οποίον κάναμε είναι ότι είπαμε ότι θέλουμε να έχουμε τουλάχιστον δέκα ι διόκτητα
τητικά μέσα έγινε μια μελέτει από το ότιμα τασόν και από την εχνηγή φρουράν για
να αντεκμηριώσει κια και πόσα είναι αυτά τα ιδιοκτα μέσα παίρνοντας το τη την έκθεση
ξαναείδαμε τις συμβάσεις εγώ ζήτησα από το γενικό λογιστήριο ένα αναλάβει να κάνει το γενικό
λογιστήριο πλέον τις συμβάσεις εκμέρους το κημά τος δάσος το κομμάτι των των πτητικών και
αυτή της στιγμή έχουμε ανοιχτών διαγωνισμόν για την αγορά τριών συμπέντ ι διότη των πτητικών
μέσων είναι σε ξέληξη οδιάγωνισμοσ λπιζόότι θα είναι γόνιμος θεωρίς ότι κάποιους τόσα χρόνια δεν
τους βόλευε να έχουμε τα τα δικά μας ρωσκά ελικόπτερα αλλά να προχωρούμε στην α